this video was made possible by a way
get the perfect suitcase for $20 off by
going to Away travel.com slash when over
20 and using the promo code Wendover 20
on July 12th 2017 Amtrak got a new CEO
the American government owned rail
company would now be helmed by Richard
Anderson Anderson was no stranger to the
American transport industry
he had previously worked for nine years
as the CEO of Delta Airlines leading it
from bankruptcy to prosperity this job
of turning around a struggling company
is rarely a popular one it requires
making difficult decisions that plenty
will not agree with but it's a job that
some leaders have a knack for having
succeeded with his task at Delta there
was at least some evidence that Richard
Anderson could complete the same task
elsewhere that's why he was brought to
Amtrak Amtrak is certainly a company in
need of turnaround while it is
government-owned it is intended to
operate as a for-profit company despite
that however it has never turned a
profit since its inception in 1971 each
year the difference between what it
makes from running its trains and what
it costs to run those trains is made up
by government subsidies grants and debt
the company's primary purpose beyond
making money is of course to carry
passengers and they don't even do that
all that well in 2018 only 73% of their
trains arrived on time in the case of
their long-distance trains just 43% got
to their destination on time in fairness
the majority of the company's delays are
the fault of the freight rail companies
that owned the tracks that carry their
trains but still it's sure that the
company could use some work so Richard
Anderson has been getting to work to
understand how Amtrak works as a company
you have to understand the types of
trains it operates there are essentially
three categories the first are the
Northeast Corridor trains this route
connecting Boston New York DC and a
number of smaller cities up and down the
East Coast is operated by both higher
speed Acela and slower Northeast
regional trains and overall the
Northeast Corridor
is by far Amtrak's most profitable route
the slower regional trains they operate
earn them a profit of almost $25 per
passenger
on the higher-speed Acela they profit
more than $80 per passenger without this
route Amtrak would be in a far poorer
financial state the second type of
trains are the state supported ones
essentially what these are are shorter
routes supported by these subsidies
offered by state governments every
single short distance train outside the
Northeast Corridor is stay supported and
this type includes routes like Charlotte
to Raleigh North Carolina Chicago to
Quincy Illinois or Vancouver Canada to
Portland Oregon
these routes range and profitability the
DC to Lynchburg train for example earns
the company almost $40 in profit per
passenger meanwhile the Fort Worth Texas
to Oklahoma City Oklahoma one loses more
than $30 per passenger over although the
state supported routes as a grouping are
unprofitable but not by that much they
are somewhat close to break-even the
third type of trains is the long
distance ones ranging from 13 hours to
65 these routes connect to big cities to
small towns all across the u.s. many of
these routes have storied histories and
strong fan bases of those who prefer the
more relaxed method of travel however
these routes certainly do not help
Amtrak's financial performance every
single one of Amtrak's long-distance
routes lose money how much money they
lose ranges anywhere from $12 per
passenger in the case of the palmetto
between New York City and Savannah
Georgia all the way to four hundred and
fifty six dollars per passenger in the
case of the Sunset Limited from New
Orleans Louisiana to Los Angeles overall
Amtrak loses more than a half billion
dollars a year operating these
long-distance routes part of what makes
Richard Anderson the perfect figure to
turn around and track is that he does
not care about trains that's to say he
has no sense of sentimentality about the
history or the grandeur or the allure of
particular storied routes his passion is
for profitability and that's his goal
seemingly no matter the cost therefore
three core parts to Anderson's Amtrak
plan have a
expanding the Northeast Corridor
services optimizing these state
supported services and cutting back the
long distance services starting with the
Northeast Corridor this is clearly
Amtrak's greatest asset the company owns
most of the tracks between DC and Boston
meaning that they don't run into the
same problems of using freight railroads
tracks like with almost all their other
services this means that they can run
these services relatively reliably and
therefore have a clear advantage over
planes or buses when traveling between
New York and DC or Boston consequently
they have cornered the market between
Boston New York and DC the first part of
Amtrak's plan to double down on this
route was initiated before Anderson even
joined the company Amtrak is receiving
new faster and larger train sets for
their higher speed Acela Express service
on the route in 2021 with the
introduction of these Amtrak has T's
plans to create four tiers of transport
for the corridor the lowest would be the
new local train operating all the way
from Richmond Virginia to Portland Maine
making most all stops along the way the
idea for this sort of super local train
would be to connect additional smaller
communities to the Amtrak network as
this service could be used to connect to
other higher speed trains the next tier
up would be existing Northeast Regional
Service operating between Boston in DC
with some continuing on into Virginia
above event would be the current Acela
Express operating limited stop service
between Boston and DC then above that
would be the new nonstop services from
DC and Boston to New York the company
launched the first of these in September
2019 with a travel time of 2 hours and
35 minutes
shaving about 15 minutes off the travel
time of the stopping SLS in the future
the addition of nonstop services from
Boston and additional frequencies from
DC will cement this as the most premium
option in the Northeast Corridor and the
idea is that these four tiered options
together will help capture more of every
customer segment thereby squeezing more
revenue out of Amtrak's most profitable
routes the fact that some of Amtrak
state-supported trains breakeven is a
fantastic sign because it means with
optimization that Amtrak can turn this
grouping profitable anderson has made
noise about expanding
Amtrak's short distance network across
the US the company has not announced any
specific new routes as part of a major
short distance expansion but it's clear
that there are opportunities trains tend
to be competitive in time and cost to
flights under a distance of about 300
miles or 500 kilometers that means that
there are plenty of likely profitable
routes that Amtrak could set up like
Dallas to Houston or Los Angeles to Las
Vegas while it's unlikely that Amtrak
could set up any additional short
distance routes without state funding
the company does have potential future
competition to private companies are
fairly serious about starting up
high-speed train service on these routes
between Dallas and Houston a company
called Texas Central Railway is months
away from starting construction on a
high-speed line connecting the cities in
just 90 minutes elsewhere Virgin Trains
USA the company that owns what is
currently the only privately owned
intercity railroad in the u.s. between
Miami Fort Lauderdale and West Palm
Beach recently acquired a company that
had begun planning and permitting work
for a Los Angeles area to Las Vegas
high-speed line and is looking to start
construction in 2020 if these projects
are completed which seems quite possible
two of Amtrak's most potentially
profitable routes will be snapped up and
if successful it would open the door to
future private rail projects in the US
while significant rail investment and
development would no doubt prove quite
beneficial for the country and help
solve many of its transport problems to
Amtrak it would get in the way of their
ability to cherry-pick the most
profitable short haul routes in order to
offset the loss of long-distance ones
that brings us to those long-distance
routes this is where things get tricky
for Amtrak as a publicly owned company
enjoying quite sizable amounts of public
funding Amtrak relies on keeping in the
good graces of the US Congress their
long-distance routes pass through more
than 40 states and cutting them would be
politically unpopular anywhere not only
do they serve as economic stimulus by
providing jobs to rural areas but many
of the country's 500 stops represent the
only public transport link to the
outside world from these small towns
there
in Congress people are well aware that
the loss of a route that their
constituents use would not help with
their popularity at the very same time
Congress has been putting the pressure
on Amtrak to cut its losses even though
the very thing losing all their money
are these long-distance routes
therefore for now the company has
started making efforts to cut cost on
these trains as one example they've
started to move their long-distance
trains away from serving fresh meals
from their onboard kitchen towards
stocking prepackaged pre-prepared foods
this undoubtedly did not go down well
with Amtrak loyalists but the whole
long-distance mess gets even messier the
company has been accused of essentially
misleading accounting practices this
would presumably be in order to make the
long-distance routes seem like bigger
money losers than they truly are in
order to help the case for their
discontinuation the company attributes
different costs to different lines to
give a sense of which make money and
which don't where this isn't always done
well for example it apparently costs
three million dollars a year to maintain
the company's electric train equipment
outside the Northeast Corridor
even though aside from a small branch
line to Harrisburg there are no amtrak
electric train routes outside the
Northeast Corridor
only diesel it also attributed all the
cost of its baggage handling services to
its long distance trains even though
these are used on many short distance
services as well the biggest highlight
of their cost attribution though is what
they mark down as the cost they bore for
their station in Miami the terminus of
some of the long-distance routes to be
cleaned of snow the last time it snowed
anywhere close to Miami was 1977 what's
likely to happen in the near future is
that Amtrak will cut the most egregious
losers in its long distance portfolio
while keeping those that are closer to
break-even in order to appease Congress
determination of any route would be a
huge loss to many they each provide
hundreds or thousands of jobs and
connect many of the country's smallest
towns to bigger cities but it's likely a
necessity given the pressure from DC the
new leader of Amtrak Richard Anderson
has though helped lead the company
towards the
goal that long seemed impossible in the
company's last fiscal year it lost just
30 million dollars in Amtrak terms that
is nothing and it puts them on track to
break-even in 2020 an achievement that
the company has never reached since its
inception 50 years ago this will occur
during what is clearly a time of great
change for Amtrak
it is reinventing itself at the
beginning of a period of a reinvention
for the American rail industry as a
whole
well many are worried about though is
that it and the Congress people behind
it will forget the difference between a
private company and a government-owned
one if Amtrak was a true for-profit
company who would have long ago made the
quite easy decision to cut every single
long-distance route doing so would
immediately turn them into a quite
profitable corporation but the company's
purpose is to connect America and
there's a whole lot more to America than
a 4-hour radius around the largest
cities
anyone who's traveled a lot and possibly
experienced the ups and downs of Amtrak
knows that not all suitcases are created
equal you can get really cheap and
flimsy suitcases or really expensive
overpriced suitcases but the key to a
perfect suitcase is to land somewhere in
between after almost three years of
usage I'm pretty certain that a way
makes the perfect suitcase I have
traveled hundreds of thousands of miles
with away suitcases and in fact as I
record this I'm traveling around Europe
using their medium back all their sizes
come packed with features they have four
fantastic spinner wheels a built in TSA
lock compression straps on the inside
and even an injectable battery in the
case of their carry-ons it all fits
together in one durable lightweight
package and they're so confident that it
includes a 100 day return window and a
lifetime warranty to get your perfect
suitcase go - away travel calm / wind /
20 and use the promo code to wind over
20 to get $20 off and that will also
help support Wendover productions